- [Instructor] We're told
that we want to factor
the following expression
that they have right here
and they say that we can
factor the expression
as U plus V squared
where U and V are either constant integers
or single variable expressions.
What are U and V?
And then they ask us to
actually factor the expression.
So pause this video and see
if you can work on that.
All right, so let's go
with the first part of it.
So they say they can factor the expression
as U plus V squared.
So how do we see this expression in terms
of U plus V squared?
Well one way is to just remind ourselves
what U plus V squared even is.
U plus V squared, this
is just going to be a,
the square of a binomial
and you've seen this
in many, many other videos.
This is going to be U
squared plus two times
the product of these two terms.
So 2UV plus V squared.
If you've never seen this before
or not sure where this
came from, I encourage you
to watch some of those early videos
where we explain this out.
But, does this match this pattern?
Well can we express
this term as U squared?
Well if this is U
squared, then U would have
to be equal to X plus seven
and when I say, actually I
should be a little careful.
Can we express this entire
thing right over here
as U squared?
If U squared is equal
to X plus seven squared,
that means that U is going
to be equal to X plus seven
and then this right over here
would have to be V squared.
If this is V squared,
then that means that V
is equal to Y squared
because Y squared squared
is equal to Y to the fourth.
So V is equal to Y squared.
Now they already told us that this,
this could be factored as the
expression U plus V squared,
but let's make sure that
this actually works.
Is this middle term right over here,
is this truly equal to
two times U times V, 2UV?
Well let's see.
Two times U would be
two times X plus seven
times V times Y squared
and that's exactly what
we have right over here.
It's 2Y squared times X plus seven.
So this kind of hairy looking expression
actually does fit this
pattern right over here.
So you can view it as U plus V squared
where U is equal to X plus seven
and V is equal to Y squared.
Now using that, we can now
actually factor the expression.
We can write this thing as being equal
to U plus V squared.
And we know what U and V are.
So this is, this whole expression
is going to be equal to
U, which is X plus seven,
and I'll put it in
parentheses just so you see it
very clearly, plus V
plus Y squared squared,
'cause that's exactly
what we wrote over there.
And of course, you don't have
to write these parentheses.
You could rewrite this as X plus seven
plus Y squared squared.
Let's do another example.
So here, once again, we are told that
we want to factor the following expression
and they're saying that we
can factor the expression
as U plus V times U minus V
where U and V are either constant integers
or single variable expressions.
So pause this video and try
to figure out what U and V are
and then actually factor the expression.
All right, well let's just
remind ourselves in general
what U plus V times U minus V is equal to.
Well, if this is unfamiliar to you,
I encourage you to watch the videos
on difference of squares.
When you multiply this all out
this is going to give you
a difference of squares.
U squared minus V squared.
If you actually take the
trouble of multiplying this out,
you're going to see that that middle term,
that middle third term, or
the middle terms I should say,
cancel out, so you're just
left with the U squared
minus the V squared.
And so does this fit this pattern?
Well in order for this to be U squared
and for this to be V squared,
that means U squared
is equal to 4X squared
so that means that U
would have to be equal
to the square root of that
which would be two times X.
Notice, U squared would be 2X
squared which is 4X squared
and then V would have to be equal
to the square root of 9Y to the sixth.
With the square root of nine is three
and the square of Y to
the sixth is going to be Y
to the third power.
And then we could use that
to factor the expression,
'cause we could say hey,
this right over here is the same thing
as U squared minus V squared,
so it's going to be equal to,
we can factor it out as, or factor it as,
U minus or U plus V times U minus V.
So what's that going to be equal to?
So U plus V is going to
be equal to 2X plus 3Y
to the third and then U minus V
is going to be equal to 2X,
which is our U right over here,
minus our V, minus 3Y to the third.
So there you have it.
We factored the expression.
You might want to write it down here
but we just did it right
up there and we're done.